and the podcast is fun though I love it
because it's something that I could do
no matter how old I get yeah right and
you get to meet so many [ __ ] cool
people yeah like Elon Trump like yeah
what was that like when when OJ when
um once Elon sat down with you were you
do you find is there a lead person who
kind of takes the lead and breaks the
ice do you kind of wait back it was it
was I kind of took lead a bit on that
one but yeah it was a bit awkward at the
beginning
because I was like you're kind of
nervous too right yeah I'm not like some
[ __ ] TV show host or some [ __ ] too
like it's Elon Musk I'm I'm pretty
[ __ ] nervous if we want to get the
best guess sometimes you only get 24
hours notice yeah like if [ __ ] Elon
Musk says like yo I want to do this like
we gotta fly to Texas jump on a plane
wait around for a few days right you
just gotta be on the ball and be
prepared did you guys have to wait for
Elon we did yeah it was a funny story I
told it before but um
what happened was like we I think it was
Sam's birthday so we took a jet to Texas
um
and then we had no service so right when
we landed we got it was so crazy because
John got like two texts uh Steve's
channels deleted like YouTube these
channels deleted and the the second
message was uh Elon message him and says
why is my security telling me that one
of the guys on your crew is a security
threat
and we're like what like what are we
talking what are they talking about and
then they said like Stephen deal an
artist
and we're like what and then
um
then we kind of put it together Steve in
the past when Bitcoin crashed he made
like a funny video like [ __ ] on Elon
and he like blew up a Tesla uh-huh and I
think he was like he had like a
mannequin of Elon and he was like
shooting guns out of him
so like I guess the security they don't
know right they don't know right right
and they probably think that's they just
see this guy shooting a [ __ ] assault
rifle like Elon and [ __ ] and asking the
flight the pilots like what's his flight
schedule and [ __ ]
so they saw that and they basically like
elon's like our whole team was set up at
his house like they they were with his
kids and like his one of his wives or
whatever and um they had to leave and
pack up and leave wow and then Steve was
like I feel so bad like and he was also
like so down about his channel so he's
like yo I'm gonna sit this one out like
I can't even do this anyway like I'm so
pissed off and then
um we kept messaging Elon back and forth
and like it went down like 48 hours
later he just ran him he was like maybe
he kept he just sends like one or two
weird answers with periods every time
only by email too
and then eventually it's just like all
right let's do it and then he just
pulled up and he stayed for four hours
no but it almost it almost didn't go
down and when he pulled up who went to
meet him first did you just you were
just sitting in that room right there
and he just walked in just with one guy
wow just walked in and he probably
crushed like six happy dads no yeah he
drinks a lot he's got yeah he he's
definitely an undercover party here I
don't even know about undercover but oh
I've heard some I heard a great story a
buddy of mine went to like a party his
whenever he worked well I think whenever
he was seeing like Amber herds right
and he like asked him if he wanted some
spaghetti or something okay yes my buddy
if he wanted some spaghetti and he's
like uh yeah I'll have some spaghetti
and so then he just like took some off
of his plate on a fork and like put it
in my buddy's mouth
really instead of like making him some
spaghetti like you know I think it
seemed like you want me to get you some
spaghetti he's he's a he's a different
kind of guy clearly right and maybe it
is more efficient maybe he's just all
about efficiency you know it's just like
it's probably more efficient if I just
give you some spaghetti that I have and
see if you want more spaghetti then go
get you a possibly wasteful amount of
spaghetti right you know but yeah my
buddy said that that was so crazy and
then there was a party where like people
would just kind of go around with like a
little drug cart and they had like
different like he's a big drug cart guy
for sure oh yeah I think you gotta be
dude he reaches his fingers in and kind
of you know takes his time makes a good
decision oh I bet he puts all the coke
out of the bag and touches it and puts
it back in the bag probably oh God mixes
it up with uh some Molly do you like
Teslas or no I think once the truck
comes out if it ever does and that's the
part that pisses me off the most is that
he hasn't brought the truck out hmm
and I don't know why it's like what the
[ __ ] going on I just don't like Teslas
yeah other cars I think they just look
kind of whatever yeah
I don't know they look kind of like a
bat it looks like if you get in there
it's gonna take you to meet some dude
yeah it's just I just don't [ __ ] with
Teslas I don't know I guess the whole
energy thing but I maybe I'm a scumbag I
just don't give a [ __ ] yeah I don't want
to run out of battery on the road like
yeah you also don't want to tell you
don't want to hike to somebody's house
in the middle of the night like my
battery's down or whatever it's not it's
not for me I'd rather just go to the gas
station
maybe I'm [ __ ] up the world but it is
what it is I don't know I don't know
sometimes I poor little gas on the
outside of my [ __ ] car dude you know
I'm not always a good guy
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one